[inaudible]
so what would you say to
the person listening that's
going, well, wait a minute,
1000 bucks,
I can't do anything with 1000 bucks.
There's basically nowhere I can get rent.
You know,
how am I going to do
anything close to a living?
Right? So for most people now,
$1,000 is not going to be enough,
but it will provide a cushion. Right?
So that's sort of the whole idea.
We're starting off with $1,000
and that's not going to be enough.
So you're still have to work.
So is that the thing? Is that the
biggest confusion related to all this?
That I think people hear ubi and they
think that it's just enough. Just enough.
So you can get by.
But you're saying that's actually
not really what's going on here.
It may not be enough initially.
Um,
I mean there may be some places
in the country, not Los Angeles,
but some places you could live on $1,000.
So if you're really in a bad
situation and you're living in La,
you could pack up and move somewhere
where maybe a thousand dollars we'll allow
you to survive. Right?
That's a possibility.
But I think but most people will do is
they will take that thousand dollars and
they will use that to sort of
cushion, um, the difficult times.
But they will still be motivated
to find a job, to start a business,
to do something there.
We just have more options,
more freedom in terms of the
choices that they make. Um,
and that's why you mentioned you're
having Andrew Yang and he actually calls
this program the freedom dividends.
That's what he's named it.
And that's exactly what it is. It
gives you more options, options,
especially for someone that's living
month to month and really has no income.
You know, the, the number of choices
that you have at in that scenario,
which is very limited.
Yeah. I guess so much of this has to do
with just the strange way we deal with
politics. So, for example,
you'll have, you know,
politicians saying we have to have $15
minimum wage and then you can walk into
Burger King or Mcdonald's now in order
on an iPad because they're basically
saying, all right, we're not
going to pay our people this much.
So everything just becomes sort
of Uber politicized, right?
That's right. And, and you know that,
that's why a basic income is maybe a
better approach because we just give it to
everyone. And the problem with raising
the minimum wage is that it may be,
you know,
good for many workers,
but it can actually also increase
the incentive to automate or,
or to do other things, right? So it
could actually result in fewer jobs.
So giving people a basic income and
preserving the incentive for them to still
work or to do other things, I think
is, is a very attractive proposition.
W when you sort of play out, you
know, five, 10, 20 years from now,
do you think things are going to just
be beyond drastically different in a way
we really can't think about because
of the speed of all of this because of
everything we've talked about here that
we really can't even envision the way is,
I think if you go out maybe a little
further than that 2030 years, that really,
really gets hard to imagine
what the future looks like. Um,
my latest book, architects of
intelligence, one of the people, you know,
it's a series of interviews
with the top people in AI.
One of the people I talk to is Ray
Kurzweil. Chris is the big futurist.
He thinks that it will be alive then we
won't be long guy. Yeah, he absolutely,
he thinks he's going to live forever.
He expects what he calls the singularity
is something that is going to
completely change the whole paradigm.
Um,
he thinks that within just 10 years
we're going to have human level,
artificial intelligence and so
forth. So that's possible. Um,
the problem is that is very unpredictable.
We don't know how fast
all of this is coming.
What I've really focused on is sort of
the practical impacts of AI and robotics
and the impact on the job market.
So what I would say is that
within five to 10 years,
we're going to definitely see a fairly
dramatic and unambiguous impact on the
job market and on the economy.
And I think ray is basically gonna live
long enough to see the robots take over
one way or another. That's
what he believes. You know,
ray is, he's already 70.
But uh,
if you've seen his photos recently,
he looks a lot younger than then
he did a while ago. So He's,
he's at least he's had some work
done. So whether the, you know,
the stuff under the hood
is, is, is better or not,
but is he the only person
doing that sort of thing?
There must be some other people. Oh, no,
there are a lot, you know, silicon valley,
there are many people very interested
in this idea of living forever and,
and advanced it, you know, the Google
People Larry Page and Sergei and, uh,
Peter Teal is very into this as well,
is even I think played
around with supposedly blood
transfusions and stuff like
that. So yes, the, the silicon
valley elite is, you know,
there are true believers in terms of
this idea that technology is going to
completely transform things in the future,
is going to be dramatically different
from the past and then we're going to
potentially even have the
possibility of living forever.
Can you explain the singularity?
The singularity basically means a point
at which technology takes off and begins
accelerating at a rate that becomes
an comprehensible to us. So they,
it comes from basically a black hole,
right?
The center of a black hole was what's
called a singularity where the laws of
physics breakdown and you can't
see beyond that point. Um, so this,
the term singularity was coined,
um,
as a way to express the idea that technol
technology reaches a point where it's
just completely unpredictable beyond
that point because things are moving so
fast.
And most people that think about this
associate that with the advance of what's
called superintelligence are
machines that are smarter than us,
not only human level intelligence,
but a machine that, that you know,
is smarter than any human being,
maybe dramatically.
So maybe so smart that it makes
us look like a mouse or an insect.
And that's where my Psi Phi brain and
every movie that I've ever seen and every
dystopian future says, well, why would
the robots need us at that point? Exactly.
If anything,
wouldn't they just see us in it as an
annoying hindrance or a vestige of the
past? And why wouldn't they
want to get rid of us? Right.
And that's a real concern,
that concern,
which is what you see in the
terminator movie. Um, and,
and even more than that,
the related concern of what's
called the control problem,
which is that if we created a
superintelligence, something
that's far beyond us,
maybe it won't actively
want to destroy us,
but it might act in ways that are not,
you know,
what our by a robot,
right. Um, and there are very, very
serious thinkers that are focused on this.
The money, the most prominent ones is
Nick Bostrom, who I also interviewed, um,
in my latest book, architects of
intelligence. So he, you know,
believes that this is a real issue and
he's working on finding ways to build
systems that will be controllable
even if they become super intelligent.
And so this is an issue
that he's focused on.
Oh, but the inherent problem being that
if you create the super intelligence,
it probably at some point
can get around that. I mean,
I know that's not mind blowing to him, but
like, right, like that's the whole idea.
Yeah. Once we have a super
intelligence, then, you know,
it's so far beyond us that we
can't control it anymore. So what,
what people are working on,
um,
is basically a principles of computer
science that will hopefully allow them to
build these systems in a way that,
that will remain aligned with what we
want them to do even when they're super
intelligent.
Right. But it's the problem with
that, what we hit on earlier,
which is maybe we here in America
hopefully figure out some systems that are
going to make some sense,
but if the Chinese figure out a system
that's a little bit different or just
some random guy in his garage in Mexico
figures out some other thing that we
still have that basically
there's just no way to manage.
It seems like a big problems.
One of
the scariest aspects of this is that
competition and the fact that there would
be an incredible first mover
advantage to whoever gets there first.
Whoever builds the first
superintelligent system,
you know, is, is going to be way ahead
of everyone else. And the reason is,
is that most people believe in what's
called an intelligence explosion or kind
of,
um,
iterative improvement where basically
once the machine reaches human level
intelligence or it gets beyond that,
it's going to turn its attention
to its own code, right,
to building better versions of itself.
So it's going to continuously engineer
a smarter version of itself and that's
something that could explode rapidly.
So whoever gets there first,
they're essentially uncatchable.
So that is going to set up a competitive
environment between the US and China
and Russia and so forth. So that's
something to worry about. Um,
but there are a lot of people
working on doing this in a safe way.
Open Ai is another good example.
That's the,
the organization it was
set up by Elon Musk, right?
And some other people and they're actively
working on building systems that they
basically, they're trying to get
there first to be the first one to,
to create a generally intelligent system
and to do it in a way that is safe.
So, um, I think that's
a good thing. There's,
there's some real focus on that
and investment in that area.
But at the same time there's also a lot
of hype people like Ilan saying some
pretty over the top things.
I do think that to some extent that's
a bit dangerous because it, again,
this is something that is
probably pretty far in the future.
I would say probably at
least 50 years of away. Um,
there is a big debate over that.
Again,
in my latest book I interviewed all
these people. I asked them this question,
how soon are we going to have a computer
that is at the level of a human being
in terms of intelligence
and the predictions I got
ranged from 10 years from Ray
Kurzweil to nearly 200 years.
Wow.
So there's a wide variation that the
average guest was about 80 years.
So at the end of this century,
so pretty cool.
What are the markers that cause people
to have a different response to that
question?
So why would someone like Kurzweil
say 10 and then someone else says 200
well, you know, there are a number of
breakthroughs that you have to have.
You have to have machines that can
learn the way people learn. Um,
right now as I said, we've got
machine learning, deep learning,
which is highly dependent on lots and
lots of data in particular labeled data.
So you can train one of these algorithms
to recognize pictures of a dog and you
would give it maybe a million
photographs that had, that was, you know,
these photos.
Would he labeled either there's a
dog there or there's not a dog there.
And based on this he could
learn and eventually recognize
dogs that a superhuman
level, but that's not the way a human
child learns, right? Um, a human child,
you can,
you can point to a dog and maybe you
only need to do that once before the kid
needs to learn.
And so one of the biggest initiatives
is teaching machines to learn from less
data in, in an unsupervised way, in
the way that that people can. Um,
and then you've got to have the ability
to think generally to conceive new ideas,
to be creative,
to understand that one thing causes
another thing is as opposed to just two
things being correlated to
develop counterfactuals to
imagine I've got this plan
for the future,
but if I tweak this one thing,
then this is what's going to be different.
These are all uniquely human ways of
thinking and it's going to take a lot of
breakthroughs, um, before we have a
machine that can do all of those things.
And there's just a lot of disagreement
even between the very smartest people
working in this field,
um,
about how long it's going to take for
those kinds of breakthroughs to happen.
How concerned are you about,
uh,
the unbiased thing that seems to be
happening when it comes to the algorithm?
So for example,
you know,
the famous case that everyone talks
about is that if you Google American
scientists, that there
is, that it happens to be,
it's just a function of things that most
American famous American scientists who
have done most of the breakthroughs,
most, not all happened to be white men.
But that Google is an
biasing the searches.
So it includes more black people
are more women or things like that,
which nobody has a problem with.
No one in their right mind has a real
problem acknowledging that there are
scientists of every color and
gender and all of those things. Um,
but they're unbiased and things that are,
that are not.
So it's not really factual sort of what
we're putting in the algorithm and that
where that could lead us see,
right. It's pretty, that's
ultimately a decision for
society I suppose how we
want to address those issues.
I remember the whole issue of bias
in algorithms is a huge issue in,
in artificial intelligence.
People are working on risking that
and that that operates in both ways.
I mean there are definitely an
absolutely have been legitimate cases of
algorithms that are biased against people
of color and so forth. For example. Um,
and gender too. I mean, I know that um,
one company for example, stopped using,
um, an AI system that we choose to screen
resumes because it was biased against
women and so forth.
And there've been other things.
Where does that bias come from in
a situation with bias? You know,
what happens is that, again,
these are systems that are
learning from data, right?
But where does that data come from
originally? It comes from people.
So if people are biased in some way
and they're generating this data,
then an algorithm, a machine
learning, I was driven,
comes along and is trained on that data,
it will pick up that bias.
So basically we're, we're the
flaw in the system. Absolutely.
More than anything else really. Right.
Um, but there is a hopeful note there,
which is that fixing bias in the
human being is very hard, right?
I mean,
we don't really know how to do that
and we know that it does exist to some
extent, but fixing it in an algorithm
could be a lot easier. Right.
It's basically tweaking some bits.
So as we bought,
I guess it depends who's doing it
though, right? Exactly. As long as,
as long as it's done in,
in, in a careful proper way.
But we can't imagine a future
where algorithms as they
were employed more maybe
as, as kind of a check on decisions
or maybe in some cases actually making
decisions. Um, it can actually be a less
biased world and not a more biased world.
But you're right,
there are huge numbers of issues
running in both directions there. Um,
well it's funny that that's sort of the
theme of all of this because I'm even
trying to sort of figure out as you're
talking, are you optimistic about this or,
or, or pessimistic about sort of
where this could all lead? And I,
I definitely sense both sides.
Yeah. I mean, I tend to be speaking
more holistically including, you know,
there are many, many issues with Ai, um,
things that we should be concerned
about biases. One security, the ability,
the ability of people, bad people
to hack into a system and, and,
and do evil things with it.
Um,
the potential for weaponization is
another thing that many people are really,
really worried about. The idea that
you can have autonomous weapons, um,
and not just one autonomous weapon that
might independently kill people without
a human in the loop, but do, you could
have thousands of them swarming, right,
which be this guy.
And that truly terrifying.
And this is something that you know,
is, is not really science fiction.
I mean,
we were talking earlier about super
intelligence and the terminator where the
machine's actively or
making a choice to kill us,
that science fiction that
lies far in the future,
but the idea of having thousands of
swarming autonomous drones that were not
intelligent independently,
but we're programmed by somebody else
to do something to attack someone or so.
So this is something that could happen.
So the idea being that,
okay,
Amazon moves to drone delivery and
then someone hacks into the system and
instead of these drones
dropping packages at our door,
they're flying through our windows and
the attack on people on the streets. Or
it could be hacking or whatever. Yeah.
Or it could be someone,
you know,
manufacturing a huge numbers of these
drones and then installing autonomous
software. Um, because you
know, the barrier to entry
here is pretty low. I mean,
these are,
these are weapons that some people could
be like weapons of mass disruption.
If you had enough autonomous drones,
that would be incredibly dangerous.
Right now if you look at something
like nuclear weapons, um,
in order for our country to have
nuclear weapons that, you know,
you've got to be a nation state,
you've got to have left, you know,
resources on that level in order
to develop nuclear weapons.
But these kinds of technologies
where you're talking, you know,
and there's a lot of um,
overlap between the commercial sector
and things that could be done on the
security or military side.
You could go on Amazon,
you could purchase a thousand drones
and then maybe you could, um, you know,
engineered them to be, to be weapons
or something. These are something that,
you know,
there's a much lower threshold there.
People in the basement somewhere could
be doing this kind of stuff, right?
So it is quite, well I think they
know already, but it is quite scary.
And many people in the Ai community,
they were very passionate
about this in particular.
There there's an initiative in the
United Nations to actually been fully
autonomous weapons for example.
And,
and the real worry is not
just the military is would
use these kinds of weapons,
but it would go beyond that
and you would have, you know,
there's kind of shady arms dealers
that now sell machine guns are selling
autonomous drones.
Um,
and so that they then become available
to terrorists and all kinds of people.
And this is, this is a really
scary scenario. One of the
people I interviewed, uh,
uh, Stuart Russell, who's
a professor at UC Berkeley,
created a youtube video
code slaughter bots.
You can go on and watch and it's really
quite terrifying and it shows you
exactly what could be done with huge
numbers of swarming autonomous drones.
And it's not, again,
it's not science fiction.
It's something that could happen
in the next five, 10 years. Do you,
uh, are you familiar at all with just
sort of the anti technology movement?
The more that you pay attention to the
technology movement and the amount of
people that are trying to either get
off the grid or limit the amount of time
online and,
and that whole thing,
right? I mean, I, you know, that,
that's I think a natural response to
a lot of this. I mean, uh, the, the,
the worst example of that is, is Ted
Kaczynski, right? The Unabomber, right?
Who actually wrote a manifesto that he,
he was published I think
in the New York Times.
But if you go and read that manifesto,
this is guided. Okay. He's crazy, right?
He's a murderer,
all of this.
But if you read that manifesto and
not know that it was written by him,
he's raising a lot of the issues that
we are now talking about. You know,
the issues that technology
could be a threat. Um,
the issue that we might
become so dependent on this
technology that we lose our
agency, right? Or ability to think
for ourselves. Um, and so far,
so, you know, even back then these people,
like we're, we're thinking about this.
And so this is a natural response in one
of the things I fear the most is that
if we don't find a way to adapt to these
technologies and find a way to leverage
all this progress on behalf of everyone
so that everyone is better off,
there's going to be a
bigger and bigger backlash.
People are going to turn
against the technology. Um,
and that might mean not just going
off the grid and living as a hermit,
but actually be, you know, becoming
much more adversarial to the system.
And that might happen politically.
It might happen in some places even in
the form of social unrest and so forth as
things get, get bad enough if
we really have unemployment.
So I just think it's critically important
that we begin to really address these
issues and have a honest discussion
about them so that we can avoid that
scenario. I assume you're a fan of black
mirror. I haven't really watched that,
but I've heard a lot about
it. But um, but yeah,
those kinds of scenarios or you know,
science fiction now,
but they are every day becoming reality.
Yeah. Is there a Scifi movie
that you think handles some
of this in the best way?
So not going all the way
to terminator tomorrow,
but like there's some movies that you
think of sort of teased out some of the
more realistic features or closer,
yeah, there, there are
several. There's one movie, um,
a few years ago called Elysium,
which really got at the issue of
inequality because what happen,
oh,
that's the one with the,
they built this love artificial sugar
and all the rich people migrated.
Aaron Earth became, became basically, um,
you know, I dystopian nightmare. All the,
all the regular people were
stuck on earth. And that's,
you're seeing that already of course
with wealthy people moving to gated
communities and so forth and elite cds
like San Francisco where things are
becoming so unequal.
And I really worry that that's the kind
of future we could have if we don't
adapt to this where you literally have
got a small number of incredibly wealthy
people that are benefiting from this
technology and are maybe using the
technology to protect themselves
from the masses. Right.
And everyone else is
literally left behind.
So that that's sort of the ultimate irony
of what's happening in Silicon Valley,
right? I mean, you just said
it. It's like San Francisco,
they've got all these great minds are
up there creating all of this incredible
technology,
absurd amounts of wealth.
And then if you go out on
the streets of San Francisco,
the amount of homelessness is,
is through the roof.
I mean crime and everything else.
San Francisco
and the bay area is ground zero
for this technological revolution.
And then right in their backyard, you
see, you see the inequality, right?
You see what's happening and um, this
is something that's going to scale out,
right. Um, to everywhere basically. Um,
so we really need to get control
of that. Um, and if we don't, it's,
I think it's got a tear off society apart,
right?
It's going to ultimately lead to some
real problems in the United States and in
other countries that are less
stable, that have less, you know,
solid institutions that we have.
It, it could be even worse.
You're going to see governments fall and
things like that in some countries as a
result of this. I think so it's really
something to be concerned about. We need,
we need to have some sort of a plan.
Yeah. Well that's what everyone's
trying to figure out right now is,
is what is that plan
exactly.
And I think this is one of the biggest
challenges we're gonna face in the future.
You know,
this is,
AI is going to be one of the primary
forces that shapes the future is going to
be incredibly disruptive.
And of course it's going
to happen in parallel with
other things. Climate Change,
um, geo politically, the rise
of China, um, migration, right?
These are all huge things
that are happening already.
All these things are
coming at us in parallel.
They're going to hit all together and
I really worry about kind of a perfect
storm. So we really need to begin
to get a handle on all that.
How does the information war
factor into all of this? You know,
one of the things that people that watch
this show are always taught, you know,
everyone's talking about fake news all
the time or that were just being handed
things.
You know,
the algorithm pushes us stories that
are favorable maybe to one side of the
political aisle or something like that.
And then we're all going to also siphon
off into our own informational realities
basically, and sort of will live in the
same physical world, but digitally we're
going to just accept different
truths. Exactly. And that, that,
that's what makes it even more scary as
to all of this disruption is coming at
us at a time when we are
just incredibly polarized,
where to some extent we're
living in different universes.
Our ability to even talk to each other,
it seems to be limited.
How are we going to, you
know, address these issues?
How are we going to respond to these
incredibly disruptive forces when we can't
even sit down and have a conversation
and agree on the same facts? Right. Um,
that's a real problem.
And,
and there is evidence that it's getting
worse and worse. That's largely the, the,
and that's why I'm doing this. This is,
so this is my little firewall right here.
Exactly.
I hope that there can be more of this
because we really need everyone and that
includes people on the left and people
on the right to be able to talk to each
other about this because otherwise we're
going to have what we have now we've
got to, we've got a congress
that literally can do nothing.
And I'm concerned no matter who
wins in 2020 the presidency,
what, you know, it's likely that the
congress will still be divided, right?
The same political polarization and
social polarization and social media
polarization will be there. So how are
we going to address these kinds of,
so that gets to what you
were talking about earlier,
that you'd need something sort of separate
from the government in a way to sort
of be,
if,
if something could oversee some of our
ability to deal with this technology,
it almost,
in a way it can't be politicized
because of the way our system is,
right? I mean I, it's stagnant
in terms of having a basic,
I think there are good reasons to
put that in the hands of a separate
institution. And the Federal Reserve
would be a good example of that.
You've seen the Federal Reserve,
which controls interest rates, right?
Is relatively independent right now. Um,
although, you know, Trump has tried to,
to, to play around with
that. But you know,
if it weren't for the fact that we
had an independent Federal Reserve,
I think we would be in much bigger
trouble now than we are. Um, and so there,
there is an argument for maybe taking
some essential functions of government
away from the political process and having
a kind of a technocratic approach to
that.
All right,
so my last question will be a two parter.
Paint me a future if we get some of
this under control and we deal with this
technology maturely and
properly give me sort of where,
what do we look like in about 10 years?
And then if we lose control and we don't
do the proper things and don't have the
proper firewalls, what does the
future look like? In 10 years?
Well, I think that, you know,
maybe looking even beyond
10 years, we know one that,
how far do you want to go that say 15,
20 years ago.
But I think that within
that kind of a timeframe,
there's going to be an unambiguous
impact on, on the job market.
So if we don't get control of this,
we will see unemployment,
at least among some workers.
We will see greatly increased
inequality even beyond what we see now.
We will see more and more anger,
um, more people left behind,
possibly even social unrest.
As a result of that,
we will see the rise of people like Trump,
which you might characterize
as kind of a demagogue,
someone that preys on the fear
that people have, right? Um,
maybe,
you know,
points to two immigrants as opposed to
technology as being the primary cause of
this and so forth.
Right?
Those other people are stealing your,
it's a lot easier to always point to
another human being than it is to point to
an intangible force like technology. So
we could have a future where, you know,
everything is just very, very ugly. On a
lot of people are, are really struggling,
uh, me on that future. And,
and the other part of that though is
that there's also an economic aspect to
that, that, that as people are
unemployed or have lower incomes,
they have less money to spend right
now they're not driving the economy,
so the whole economy suffers.
So we could have also a financial crisis,
the recession,
um,
perhaps people can't pay their debts and
we get into a situation like we had in
2008. Right? So that's, that's
sort of the worst case scenario.
The best case scenario is that
we find a way to adapt to this.
Maybe it was something
like a basic income.
So we addressed this issue of people not
having jobs or not having an adequate
incomes.
So they still have money to spend.
They go out and they spend
their money in the economy.
There are all kinds of new products and
services and exciting things for people
to spend money on. There is incredible
opportunity for entrepreneurs,
for people like Elon Musk's or the next
Steve and Steve jobs to create things.
Um, based on this new technology and
people have income that they need to,
to buy these products. Um, things do, um,
in large measure get less
expensive. So people you know, have,
have greater purchasing power.
Um,
we have enormous breakthroughs
in science and medicine. Um,
we all live longer and healthier lives.
So there are enormous benefits
to artificial intelligence.
It's going to become the primary tool
that's used in scientific research and
solving problems like climate change,
developing new forms of clean energy,
you know, medical
breakthroughs, all of that.
The key thing is that we want to make
sure that we get that stuff and then we
get it for everyone.
In other words,
we want to be able to leverage it on
behalf of everyone rather than just a few
people. And I think that if we can
find a way to navigate through this,
that it's incredibly, um, optimistic.
And where it kind of ends up in the far
future is maybe something like Star Trek,
right?
Where,
where you've got what has been called
kind of the post scarcity economy,
an economy of abundance where you know
people don't have to worry about the
basics of life anymore than people you
know, focused on other things, right?
I mean, and star track, you've
got to materialize or right you,
everything is basically free.
People don't have to work a
nine to five job to survive.
They are out traveling
the universe or whatever.
I'm doing things that are genuinely
meaningful to them and I think that's sort
of the vision that we should have as
we anticipate the development of these
technologies. But in order
to get there, we've got
to be honest,
I'm serious lifter
what the implications of this is.
We need to have an honest
discussion and come up,
I think ultimately with some real
policies to address the risks and the
downsides that are going to come
with this progress. So we shall see.
I hope these are the three words that'll
start to take us out of this one.
We should probably do this every year.
You want to do one of these every year
and just pick up on all the incremental
progress. And then I suppose if
everything you're saying is right,
one year we're going to do
it and everything will look
so absolutely different.
We won't even be able to look back and
make any sense of what we're talking
about. Once we get past that singularity,
you're going to be different.
I look forward to it
and for more on Martin,
you can follow him on
Twitter at m forward future.